[Applause]
thank you very much I'm very glad to be
here and first let me introduce myself
briefly my name is Nikita and I work at
made safe but it's a company that
develops very barren Network and so my
day job is kind of related to the topic
of my today's talk and today I want to
talk to you about WebRTC and for those
who don't know it's an html5 technology
that's commonly used to transfer video
and voice data Google Hangouts uses it
as well as many other tools that you
might have used to talk to other people
directly in your browser it's been
available in most of the major browsers
for a while since at least year to 2012
I guess on both desktop and mobile
platforms but actually web RTC is
capable of much more than simply
transferring media and in fact in my
opinion WebRTC is able to spark a new
decentralisation revolution and help in
building a new internet so my goal today
is not a teacher about all the intricate
details of this technology but to
inspire you to take to take you to take
action and help to bring that revolution
closer
but there is a reasonable question that
you might have why do we need that
revolution at all do we need a new web
like the current one works quite
perfectly now right well in my opinion
it does but at the same time the web and
the internet were created a long long
time ago and on the fundamental level
they're a little bit flawed because the
internet was originally conceived and
created as a completely decentralized
network that no single authority can
control and the web as well was thought
of as kind of a cyberspace where every
human being is not in control of any
government or any corporation and that
they have complete freedom to say what
they think and what they want and the
web was a place without any censorship
however lately this situation has
changed drastically nowadays the web is
largely dependent on big corporations
that run our infrastructure like giant
data centers and they provide many
useful services like email for example
it wasn't always like that though at
first people set up and run their own
email servers and control their own
communications this approach was not
scalable so so natural consequence was
that a lot of small commercial email
email providers sprang up at first they
were small and if he was there at the
early days of the web you might remember
that it was a great feeling
to just create your accounts and get
access to whole 10 to 15 megabytes of
your own inbox space but then something
has changed the more people started to
use the internet the more our services
are consolidated around just a few of
big providers and the result of that is
that now our email usage is confined
just a few giant services and almost no
one runs their own servers and that's
pretty understandable because it's just
too inconvenient and not even strictly
required to deal with all that spam all
by yourself and handle all those
daunting administration tasks and
actually what happened to email is not
unique we have seen the same process
follow it for almost anything we use and
see on the web and despite the email
protocol itself being decentralized as
many of other original internet
protocols like a [ __ ] before instance or
FTP we don't have centralized
authorities that we depend upon and
previously we had a concept of home
pages we could which you could serve
from your own home computer and put
there anything you would like now you
can kind of still do that but far more
people just create their Facebook or
Twitter profiles and now that what they
can write and their profiles are
determined not by people themselves by
but by the policies of these websites
it's like that so we have exchange tile
control and our privacy for convenience
and now the large corporations can tell
us what we can say on the internet now
it depends on those centralized services
to do many things to share files through
Dropbox we share messages through
servers that we can control we pay with
PayPal you might ask why is it bad
though isn't that protocol to bring
millions and now even a billion of users
to the Internet well of course these
services are very nice and there is
nothing wrong with them as such but it's
not only about the freedom of speech
it's also about the fact that government
started to snoop into our private data
and communications in the name of good
things like predicting children or
protecting the world from terrorism and
while these intentions are good the
consequences of allowing other people to
read your private data are not the more
power the governments have the more
likely it is
that they will use this power in the
wrong way and this is uh not some kind
of theoretical or imaginable problem
because this is our reality already in
countries like turkey Russia and China
where they block hundreds and thousands
websites that they deem inappropriate or
bad but actually what website you can
name is bad different cultures have
different concepts and understanding of
of that and inappropriate but it's just
you easy to use this excuse of a bad
website to introduce censorship and
silence the political opposition and we
have seen that here already even in
European countries like when Spain
blocked websites and censored
information that was related to their
friend in Catalunya and of course we all
know about the case of NSA the American
spatial agency that collected private
data of people from all around the world
so with the power of social networks
which are very large part of our lives
now the governments and corporations can
have another present its control over
their lives or something like that
can we change these beliefs current
state over that I believe that began we
just need to rethink the web from
scratch and that might sound impossible
to you at first but we can create the
centralized networks and the centralized
web apps that are just as easy to use as
any other modern-day web application and
I personally believe that the user
experience is even more important than
privacy or anything else because why
would you use an app that frustrates
your you don't understand how to use
properly that's one of the reasons why
so many privacy's Android applications
failed in the past like take for example
PGP and mio encryption which are
bulletproof but at the same time they're
also just inconvenient for everyday use
and almost no one increases their immune
email messages nowadays so that's also
the reason why so many the surprise
Network failed as well and that's why we
need to incentivize users to
is applications that are aware of these
privacy concerns and I believe that
diversity can be the answer now it's
already available in most browsers and
you don't need to install any software
or a browser plug-ins for it to work you
just open a web page and it connects
directly to same users as you without
passing data through any intermediary
servers and a lot of people use forever
to see now to transfer media but not a
lot of people know that it can also be
used to transfer any arbitrary text or
binary data in an addition to that
despite having weapon its name it's not
confined to the web only and the
protocol itself is open and you can use
it from anywhere not only from a browser
and that's a very powerful idea because
you can create a beber this application
that reberty's applications that work on
desktop or Internet of Things devices
all these devices will be compatible
with web browsers and you can
communicate with them directly skipping
any third parties that together and
analyze your private data
Roberta C can also be used to create
general-purpose and large-scale
peer-to-peer networks which do not
depend on centralized servers or any
authorities it can also play a
significant role in the recent trend of
raid centralization or bringing back the
Internet to its origins there are
already exist a lot of decentralized
applications that we use every day it
all started with BitTorrent and Bitcoin
which showed that global scalable
peer-to-peer networks are possible and
today not a small part of the world's
Internet traffic consists of Bitcoin
Bitcoin usage and this is where
important fact that shows that
decentralized apps are not purely like
abstract or theoretical and that they
are needed by the people so reberty see
can serve as a kind of a bridge to
existing peer-to-peer networks and with
its help that can create a lot of new
networks as well
on the practical side the vibrating capi
is simple it's a bit hard when it gets
to establishing gas connection as we
will see but for the message passing
it's really similar to the websocket api
just to initialize a data channel which
is a data stream between two peers you
set a callback function that will be
called each time you get a new message
and then you can send a message to
itself the other side will get it and
the own message callback will be
triggered and that's almost all you need
to know about exchanging messages in the
RTC and behind the scenes the protocol
guarantees that your messages will be
encrypted
the encryption thief is defined in the
standard and it is mandatory you don't
need to do anything to set it up the
session encryption keys will be
automatically created during the
connection and tells a ssin step so our
communications are secure and they can
be tapped by anyone but most importantly
you have to set up the connection
properly first and you do that
eventually you need to understand the
concept of signalling which is quite
complex topic by itself but to put it
simply it's a connection stage when
peers share their IP addresses and
encryption keys with each other and they
do that through some point of exchange
that they have a great opponent advance
that point of exchange can be
practically anything and WebSocket
server and mail exchange for some secure
chat it doesn't matter
some people might consider it this point
of exchange as a kind of a
centralization or a single point of
failure though and in some sense it is
but it's not really centralized because
the way you do signalling is not defined
in the WebRTC standards itself and it
gives you a big extent of freedom in
choosing the most efficient way that
suits your application best so it can be
compared to DNS if your Gena's server
doesn't respond to your request you can
always still get to the server if you
know it's a be address right so have
that information can bypass some of the
centralized parts of the internet
architecture infrastructure and the same
thing basically applies to ever to see
if you know IP addresses of your peers
they can exchange the session
information with them directly and when
they get that information you won't need
to deal with any kind of centralized
servers anymore and now that we have
learned the basic concepts we can try to
establish our vertice connection which
is a bit more complicated than the data
channels API but when you learn it it
becomes for other intuitive so what we
need to know about it is that there are
two sides of the handshake process and
the connection the initiator and the
recipient the initiator creates an offer
which contains the session encryption
key and in case if you want to stream
media it will also contain the
information about media encoding
available codecs and so on so when an
initiator has created an offer they need
to sell it as a local description of the
connection which will tell the browser
how it should decode the incoming
messages as a final step you need to
send your offer to the recipient through
the signaling channel which again can be
a web secure connection or whatever you
choose it to be and on the other end the
party that you want to connect you the
recipient receives an offer through the
signaling channel and then they follow
almost the same exact steps only at this
time they will need to set your offer as
a remote description instead which which
will tell the browser how it should
encode the outgoing messages then the
other end should create an answer which
in turn will contain their encryption
keys and the session information they
set it as their local description and
then send it through the same signaling
channel to the initiator party finally
when the initiator gets the answer they
just set it as their remote description
and now both parties should have the
full information to exchange messages
both should know it
there's encryption keys and now we can
forget about the signaling server for
now but not really because you also have
to care about exchanging not only the
encryption keys
between the two parties but also and
most importantly and most crucially
their connection information that is you
need to know an IP address of the other
side to connect to them directly and
there is a key that for the direct
connections because in the real world
most likely you will have to deal with
Nats or network address translators most
people deal with Nats in the form of
rooters switch translate addresses from
your local network to their real
internet IP addresses and in fact it's
not unusual to see case when behind a
single global IP address there are
several hundreds devices in the local
network area and we need Nats because
the IP version 4 address space is
limited with 4 billion addresses and we
have a lot more devices in the both now
and because of Nats direct connections
to peers in peer-to-peer networks become
complicated
you have to bypass this mess with one of
the natural result techniques and this
task is a bit complicated because
because of the fact that there is no
single standard way for Nats
there's no single standard way to
structure Nats but there aren't many of
them kocoum
port restricted symmetric Nats and even
more non-conventional configurations and
each type requires its own approach to
bypass it but the good thing is these
techniques are well known and in the
simplest case it works in a pretty
straightforward way you just send a
request to some external address and
that opens a port so that the external
party could send you a response now if
you know that port number you can just
reuse it and send it back to your peer
along with your public IP address and
now that that knows that any data that
gets to the sport should be forwarded to
you you can communicate with your peers
directly
and WebRTC takes care about all of that
for us so we don't need to be involved
in that at all all their support from us
is to collect our public IP address and
afford and transfer them to our peer
through the signaling channel but you
have to discover your own IP addresses
and port in the first place like most
often you would do that through stun
stun is a basic protocol that allows you
to get your own IP address by sending a
request to a stun server which basically
acts as a kind of a mirror a sentry
request from your local network and the
stun server sees your translated address
and the port and send them back to you
and then you just need to broadcast them
through the signaling channel it is a
simplest case through because sometimes
for various reasons your peers can't
connect you directly like in the case
when you're behind the symmetric net
which will have a random port numbers
assigned for each connections and but
this problem can be solved as well with
the other teams to bypass Nets it is
called turn but turn is a kind of last
resort because it basically works as a
proxy server relay in traffic between
peers obviously turn is a costly
solution and you can't find a turn
server in the wild as opposed to stun
which is commonly provided by many
servers there is a Google stun server so
you can find a lot of them but luckily
you won't need to resort to turn in many
cases because symmetric Nats are not
that common
so to exchange the connection
information there exists another special
protocol that WebRTC uses which is
called ice ice helps to discover all
candidates or IP addresses and port
payers by combining marie's in the
traversal techniques it also collects
your local IP addresses so your peers
are on the local network
you won't even need to go through the
internet to connect to them so with ice
we gather all candidates that we can
find and send them to the other party
which tries to use them all at once as
synchronously meaning they will try to
connect to us through all available
means and finally hopefully resulting in
a successful connection and the WebRTC
implementation of this protocol allows
us to concentrate on the application
side because all that it requires from
us is that team to provide that we need
to provide the stun and turn server
addresses then we set a callback
function and sandwich collected
candidate through the signaling channel
in all the other end our peer listens on
the signaling channel for incoming ice
candidates and tries to use them as soon
as they come in the real world however
it's a bit much a bit more nuanced but
basically that's all we need to know
about setting up basic emergency
connection however what we have seen so
far was just the most simple possible
topology what set up a connection
between just two peers which can be
useful of course but usually you imagine
peer to peer networks is having more
actors like if you have just two peers
in your network you can just have a chat
or exchange files with other person but
it's not that useful and if they want to
connect more peers to your network
that's where it starts to get more
complicated with multiple peers there
are many ways to structure the p2p
network you can just connect all peers
to each other but it won't be the most
efficient way to do that because if you
transfer large files or voice or video
data it will have to duplicate this
traffic traffic for each connection and
it might work for small connection with
four or five peers but at one scale to
hundreds and even tens of years it will
just require
no too much bandwidth and processing
power there's an answer to that problem
too you can choose one or more peers
that have the most processing power and
make them serve all other peers relating
to traffic and multiplexing requests
this is called star topology and it is
pretty efficient it is also secure
because the serving peers still won't
have access to the session encryption
keys but at the same time your network
will start to rely on a single point of
failure and it will depend on a good
behavior of just a couple of notes so it
will be kind of centralized again it is
efficient for transferring a video and
voice data though and many such
applications use it like Google Hangouts
for instance but there are also many
more alternative ways of structuring p2p
networks this topic is a bits out of
scope of this talk unfortunately because
it's it will be easy to spend at least
30 minutes more to talk just about one
of the algorithms so we can just mention
that one of the prominent ones is the
distributed hash table which has many
different implementations it is also
used by the BitTorrent Network for
example and many of us have used be
turned at least once and this protocol
also has an interesting history because
at first it dependent on centralized
trackers to find the connection info and
IP addresses of peers that serve files
that you are searching for and this has
an obvious disadvantage of trackers
being that authorities are able to log
the trackers and then you can can't find
their current connection information and
then you can download the file so now in
BitTorrent and supports the distributed
hash table algorithm so all you need to
do is just find a single pair to
bootstrap from because requests for
files can be propagated throughout the
network with several hops instead of
relying on a single
failure and the process of the initial
connection to the network is now usually
done by just by contacting a well-known
node and then it can continue to work in
a decentralized way because each node
knows about its neighbours or theirs
knows who contacted them so if you know
at least a single IP address of a
patrolling node you can join the full
network and now an interesting question
what will happen if we can bind the big
current with WebRTC we get web torrent
which has a bitter end protocol
implementation for JavaScript which can
work in browsers as well as on the
server side and also it can communicate
with BitTorrent peers directly from a
browser because of incompatible Network
protocols it still allows us to do a lot
of interesting things and it simplifies
the interaction with the verticity
recall a lot we don't need to care about
signaling and all that stuff all we have
to do is to serve a file to the network
and this file will be automatically
converted into the torrent and announced
on the tracker behind the schemes and
that point has a pretty straightforward
API you can serve basically anything as
a file can be a blob a JSON object or
even a JavaScript stream other peers
knowing that torrent hash can download
this file and set it further in files
are generally not limited to a Linux
distribution archives or whatever you
usually download from torrents any
information can be represented as an
abstract file so web turn can be used
for much more than just file sharing for
instance we can build a distributed
github quite easily because git
extensively uses and relies in hashes
for its internal implementation and so
it will be a very straightforward to
serve the get packed objects through
torrents there is an proof-of-concept
project called get torrent that already
does just that and we can reuse the same
protocol to serve web pages or static
content and make a kind of
distributed content delivery network so
that each visitor of your website will
serve the website's content to each
other visitor and you didn't find many
more applications of the BitTorrent
protocol but still despite of being very
promising whatever he sees in mature
technology it still needs to come a long
way to support large-scale networks that
can transform the current centralized
state of the web it's not perfect and
has many limitations the browser support
is not perfect for instance and current
modern web browser such as Chrome or
Firefox stolen at a number of
connections that you can establish and
because of this limitation and because
of the handshake overhead
it's practically impossible to build DHT
networks which made the web for
implementation dependent on the
centralized trackers for now in addition
to that Weber GC doesn't allow to allow
us to use raw sockets so you can't
connect to the existing networks
directly they'll have to go through the
proxies and another important issue is
that browser sessions are usually
short-lived when you close your tab you
know lows you will lose all connections
and the next time you will have to go
through the costly signaling and the
connection initiation process again this
problem can be theoretically alleviated
by allowing to run WebRTC sessions in
service workers so that even if you
close a tab with a very juicy connection
you will still maintain your connection
to the network of peers but it's kind of
not possible for now and it's currently
being developed another possible
solution to the problem of short-lived
sessions is hybrid servers because as I
said earlier the Beverley's
implementation is not limited to
browsers so we can integrate the WebRTC
protocol support into the existing
peer-to-peer networks and they can act
as kind of intermediary servers still
well there is a there is a lot of
problems to overcome WebRTC is very
useful today and I'm hoping to see many
new
projects that used this particle but
between networks in general have their
own set of problems to solve because
these networks are trustless it's hard
to solve the problem of malicious peers
for instance which can span your network
work misbehave in order to gain some
advantages in a fist or contained and
multiple nodes but step under the
territory of distributed systems which
are very complex because we'll have to
deal with data consistency in churn
because imagine that all knows that
store some file on the network leave all
at once effectively this file will be
lost and it's completely fine if that
file has no value to you like if it's on
another of Justin Bieber songs or
whatever but imagine if that file was
your Bitcoin wallet you certainly
wouldn't want to lose it that's why for
redundancy we have to make sure to have
enough copies of the same file
distributed over mail well over many
nodes and it is not definitely not an
easy task to coordinate nodes which
don't trust each other so if we are
talking about a long lasting global
scale network we need to make sure that
Pearson these networks are incentivized
to stay and in my opinion the economy of
p2p networks is even more important than
their algorithms because not a lot of
people would want to share their
resources if there is no reward for them
but can kind of solve this problem by
giving some coins to mining nodes but
it's tricky because some strategies can
lead to centralization all over again we
have seen that on the same example of
Bitcoin where mining is now largely
consolidated around just a few large
pools and remember that the Internet
itself originally was started as a
distributed network - but the question
of who provides the resources and who
serves the webpages leads us to use in
modern days of giant centralized data
centers and mega corporations so this is
an open question and we ought to look
for an answer because I think answering
this question will be very beneficial
for very beneficial for all of us
we can do a lot with WebRTC and we can
confirm the current internet we can
bring existing p2p networks such as tor
to web by putting them to dissemble and
adding the WebRTC protocol support we
can build new p2p networks that point
depends on the will of governments and
greedy corporations these networks can
be used to get back the control over
data to the people because they are more
secure and resilient in the application
of a bird ECM will be especially
important in the area of Internet of
Things as we can see that medical
devices self-driving cars smart homes
and critical infrastructure already
depends on the internet which is by and
large controlled by a few big players
now and I strongly believe that it's not
right to give these mega corporations
and governments even more power and
control over our data and consequently
or our daily lives so you can find me on
Twitter and there is a link to page
listing some is for resources related to
this talk and thanks a lot for your
attention
[Applause]
you